any CEO who's worth his or her salt is
constantly assessing what they do well
and what they could improve there's no
CEO is perfect having metem probably
doesn't exist or her doesn't exist but
what a great CEO does is constantly
course-correct you take an action you
say what did I do well here and what can
I do better and I think that's probably
the best thing I've seen him whether as
a candidate or now as president is hey
I'm not going to get it all right all
the time but and and you know even if we
take the healthcare peace you can look
now and you if you sort of look at when
it was first put on the table and where
we are today and what's going to be
happening in the weeks to come as we try
to sort of you know refrain we frame it
and what some of the options are that's
what a great leader does and so I would
give him you know has he had stumps and
bumbles absolutely do all CEOs have
stumps and mobiles absolutely but the
great ones are the ones who say hey
didn't do that as well as I could have
and get back into it and and work at
course correction that's what that's the
kind of flexibility and ability to sort
of look at the big picture that he does
exceptionally well
I think the biggest one and I find that
I will always believe this is being
you're being yourself being authentic
because I think for people and I've had
a chance to see this over many years
when people are really themselves
they're really able to express their
thinking and their thoughts and their
actions in a way that's consistent with
who they are and then I'm very
successful it's really important that
your authentic so that when you go
through an interview process you're not
trying to sort of fit into a particular
job because you think that's the job
everybody says you should be interested
in taking you know so many people sort
of went down to Wall Street because they
felt it was the place to go and verse is
saying oh you know I like the the
creative side of things I like marketing
I like making things I want to be a part
of that and yeah maybe i'm not going to
necessarily make the money if i went in
the financial space but i'm going to do
something that's sort of really true to
what I'm interested in and I think those
people give myself an example you know
when I went into product management it
was the lowest salary offer that I had
coming out of business school but I
loved it and I did well and I you know
excelled and you know eventually over
time maybe not quite caught up with some
of my peers who were successful on Wall
Street but you know I did okay I made a
good living
I know this is going to sound really
corny I tend to come back to both of my
parents I really really do my mother
worked at a time when there weren't a
lot of working women and moved ahead in
government my dad always always talked
to everybody he met whether it was
people in the supermarket who worked
there the clerks the people putting the
produce out and and I really learned
from him that everyone has value that
were all little people you know people
tended say you know people talk about
little people we're all little people
were all the same and and those things
really stick with me because I saw how
they live their lives and in many
respects you know never coming close to
maybe making the money that I'm making
but having a rich life and being well
respected and I think that's very
important I think sometimes we tend to
want to look at the people who are the
very public people and I say you know
don't always look for the people who are
the public personas that we want to
admire and the celebrities know you
gotta look for the day-to-day people who
are doing the right thing raising their
families through challenging times but
really making a difference in their own
way